I have summoned you all here for the
10th Annual reaping ceremony in which we
choose two children from each district
to fight to the death and The Hunger
Games from District 12 Lucy gray
[Music]
bear there has been a change this year
as a mentor Mr snow Your Role is to turn
these children into spectacles not
surpris Suzanne writes very
cinematically and she probably
understands having worked the other
movies what does and does not translate
and I suspect she's also smart enough
not to be too precious about what is
gained and what is lost but when you
walk in there is it a different
experience than the other books which I
think had been published when you were
starting to work on them we were all
very curious about you know what sort of
story she wanted to tell and what the
themes were going to be and all of that
but you know the writing was the same
and she does think very cinematically
you know she actually started from um
writing screenplays for children
television so she's very you know in
tune with what a screenplay needs um and
also really good with the adaptation
process because of that feels like the
district have style but no money whereas
people in the capital have money but no
style I wanted this time around because
of what we have for Lucy gray and this
rainbow dress to show that District 12
besides the coal mining area that they
have this really you know like a
Heritage of dance and sing in and
celebration before the capital has had
their hands so controlling them so I
kind of flipped it this time around and
I went with more color and patterns in
the district and then in the capital
made them much more controlled and
classic and contained whereas in the
later films or the earlier films it's
more colorful in the capital so I kind
of wanted to flip that around this time
so that we could show that the districts
have all this life and this happiness
and it's really the capital that people
are living under the thumb of the
government so you are
64 years before and I guess if we're
looking thinking modern day world we're
kind of post-war late
postwar is that part of your thinking
because it does feel you're shooting in
Germany but it feels post-war Germany
but also post-war America in terms of
the suits and what people are wearing
was that part of the conversations we
really looked at um postwar Berlin as
kind of an anchoring point for us in
terms of a lot of choices like what is
the reubel in the streets how are they
rebuilding the classical buildings what
are the new buildings that are being
erected what are the color palletes we
even started to look at that time period
and you know the late 40s even early 50s
in terms of technology in terms of um
you know hair makeup all of those things
that kind of became the era we looked at
for a lot of our aesthetic choices when
you get on set is it ever an issue that
the color doesn't work on set I'm
thinking about the red behind us there
are all sorts of different Reds the red
against the gray do you know what that's
going to look like photographically or
do you try many iterations of red in
terms of depth and richness of the color
to see how how it photographs against
the sets you have that kind of time um
You by the time we get to set we know
what everything is going to be in
general we have a sense of what the sort
of you know like if you're thinking
about G's lab we've seen iterations of
the costume we've done costume tests
with Viola in the lab coat we know that
R is like yo the cinematographer and I
have already talked about during the day
the lab might have like a cyan kind of
quality and at night it might be a
little more Amber OE and I have you know
talked about you know all of this and
has been part of all these conversations
um you know so by the time we're doing
it we really know how all of this stuff
is going to work occasionally you get
surprised by something you know there's
always something that slips through the
cracks but in general we we really have
a very solid idea of of how it's all
going to work and what about the capitol
Academy they're almost unisex it feels
like they have they're tunics but they
also have kind of almost a skirt element
how would you describe your design
Philosophy for what the academy uh
students are wearing we see several
films with school uniforms in them and a
lot of a lot of very iconic so I wanted
to do something completely different and
in my mind it was the thing with the
capital again seeing the locations and I
asked Francis after seeing the locations
and I use red because there was so much
gray and I like the idea of seeing the
kids go the students go up the stairs
just like the you know these Vinings of
blood that all flow into the capital and
I wanted them to again have something
very classic about the uniforms but then
let us you know move a bit forward it
wouldn't really look like the 40s and
the 50s because again these people in
the capital and these students I feel
are of Youth today they're the more
fashioned forward they're the ones that
are on the edge of things when you are
working on a movie that has a huge fan
base and yet you're working in a
different world that's preceding what
those fans are going to come to love how
do you manage to be true to what those
fans might want and what the books say
and what you want to do in a new world
in with new characters and new actors to
create something new something new so
where's that tension in terms of you
know mindful of the but also creating
new worlds that you think are distinct
from the other the other films the
biggest tension for me was before
reading the manuscript when I was just
wondering what the appetite would be for
a Hunger Games movie without catniss
right and but then I read the manuscript
and I fell in love with the story and
the truth is that's all I kind of need
um to want to sort of commit to trying
to figure something out and challenge
myself to make it and I fell in love
with the story um I'm also a fan of the
books and I'm a fan of the fans and I
understand what they love about it and
so the truth is is that when we make
these decisions and we're we're sort of
trying to find the kind of history and
it's almost like doing kind of
archaeology on these things it's all
based out of loving these stories and
loving these characters and loving the
world and what what it's all about so I
never worried for a second about
pleasing the fans I just worried whether
or not people wanted to see Hunger Games
movie without Katniss mhm there are some
little Easter eggs right is it a is it a
primrose and a Katniss that if you watch
this movie on your laptop you're going
to miss but thank goodness we have big
screens here with highdefinition
projection is that do you do that
another places where there's like a
little Easter egg because I noticed that
I suspect people who know the stories
notice that as well yeah I wanted to I
did want to have a few Easter eggs
whether it's even just for myself that
tied in you know the the pre previous
films especially Katniss and like snow
tying them into the new characters and
also it was a thing I wanted to offer to
Rachel as well because I knew there'd be
a lot of pressure for she's not Jen
Lawrence she's not Katniss and so I
wanted to kind of give her this little
Shield to move forward with of saying
there is a little Katniss with you on
this corset you know and there's also
Primrose and then the snakes so that I
did you know selfishly and also for the
film but and you know and had a great
team that did all the hand painting like
I mentioned we had to do 10 of those and
exactly the same and you know there's
that one and then there's kind of at the
end um with Tom when he's the new man
and he goes to see high bottom there's a
a costume that I put on Donald
southernland and catching fire that's
the same color the same kind of shoulder
a little bit more you know futuristic in
shape but it was kind of mimicking that
and showing where this transition could
lead Suzanne has a ear for music she's
written lyrics how do you go about
honoring what she's written and making
sure it's something a your actor can can
perform and B sounds right ass played
she said there was going to be a music
element to this and I was very curious
and then I read it and I was amazed that
there was all this music and obviously
you know a main character that's a
performer and a singer and the great
thing is is that Rachel one of the
reasons we cast her is she's truly a
remarkable singer the only worry was
that most of the singing we'd heard
sounded like Westside Story it was of
Broadway kind of singing like was she
going to find the voice of Lucy gray for
this this music she fell right in she
totally got it she totally nailed it um
we did these pre-record that were more
like
rehearsals um but then she was actually
able to sing live and she sing live live
to picture on every day every day so
whether it's a performance in the hob on
mic or whatever or with the snakes
anytime she sings in this movie she sang
Live on the day impressive last question
what was the biggest creative challenge
for you on this on this shoot yes what
was the
biggest let me I I I can't even narrow
it was it limited to what you're doing
on this film or did it have to do with
what has come after I I think the
biggest challenge on this was as Francis
mentioned like what's the appetite for
seeing the film again and and knowing
that all the other films have this
really large element of what the capital
look like and the big hair the big
costume
so it was trying to figure out how we
could be true to the story that we
wanted to tell and what Suzanne wrote
and make it really interesting and
something new to see that's quite
different but just still have this
appeal so the biggest challenge was that
and the rainbow dress right and what
you're talking about is honoring the
past in a way and also being present and
creative in in the present um seems like
backward timelines but I think that's
the way it worked what about for you
what was the biggest creative challenge
I me this I think sort of Beyond beond
like beyond the worry that we've already
talked about I think once we got into
creating the story it was in in the
adaptation process the the the biggest
challenge for us me Suzanne the
screenwriters Nina the producer was you
know we knew we were telling the story
about a young man's descent into
darkness and this is a story where we
have to get an audience behind the
person they know is the villain of the
other movies and so it was this trying
to get people to empathize with him be
able to relate to him be you know
wanting to get an audience rooting for
him I think that that was the biggest
challenge Francis and Trish I want to
thank you for coming out and for making
this film thank you so much appreciate
it thank
you